welcome to the National Museum of
American history I'm Jeffrey stomach
I'm curator of engineering and
environmental history in today's program
represents the museum's ongoing series
meet the author and our special guest
today is Jace a mule Walker the topic of
why I should say that some of you may
have read that Ivan Selim had been
scheduled to interview dr. Walker and
dr. Selim expresses his regrets he was
not able to make it at the last last
minute the topic of today's book
discussion coincides with several events
going on in the museum which observed
the 25th anniversary of the accident at
Three Mile Island on the second floor is
a small exhibition that looks at the
discovery of what happened inside the
core you're all welcome to visit it if
you go after immediately after this
program the curators that develop that
exhibit will be there to answer your
questions on Sunday at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon we're presenting a panel
discussion with distinguished former
members of public officials who will be
sharing their recollections reflections
on how the government at the state level
White House the federal government how
they respond how they dealt with the
crisis it should be very good at Sunday
at 2:00 today's topic book discussion
deals with dr. Walker's new book Three
Mile Island a nuclear crisis in historic
perspective Sam is a historian with the
US Nuclear Regulatory Commission at the
NRC had hired Sam appropriately enough
not long after the accident at Three
Mile Island Sam is a distinguished
American historian he's been given many
prizes for his scholarship this book is
his seventh and I don't know that it
makes any difference one way or the
other
but I thought you would like to know
that Sam grew up in Lancaster
Pennsylvania not that far from Three
Mile Island and he still has family
members living in the area Sam maybe you
can tell us something about the project
how how it got started or your get
launched on this Thank You Jeffrey yeah
Jeffrey mentioned that I started with
the NRC as historian in June of 1979 and
I and I tell people we haven't had two
major accidents since and I don't know
if there's a connection there or not but
I don't die don't probe too deeply about
that what I'd like to do for just a few
minutes is talk some about the process
of writing this book Jeffrey and I are
going to talk about the contents of the
book in in a few minutes but I thought I
would talk just briefly about the the
process of writing this book my job with
the NRC as as the historian of the NRC
is to write skali histories of the on
the subject of a nuclear regulation and
I tell people in all honesty that I've
got the best job in the government I'm
paid every other week to do research and
writing on a topic that I find of great
interest and that other people
apparently find of interest at least my
phone has been ringing off the hook for
the last three weeks so so people
certainly have an interest in Three Mile
Island the book on Three Mile Island and
I'll call it TMI everyone calls it TMI
so there's no no reason to try to change
that today the book on the TMI is a
fourth in a series of books that I have
written the first I co-authored with
with my former colleague George miss
Susan who is here today and since George
left the NRC to take another job I have
written three other books so the book on
the 3-mile and is a fourth in a series
and I should say I suppose that the NRC
has allowed me indeed expected me to do
my scholarship as the agency historian
according to the highest standards of of
historical scholarship and I hope that I
have have met that standard
I certainly have tried to do so and what
the NRC expects me to do
so tell it like it was to tell the story
as I see it based on the research that I
do in the case of Three Mile Island
telling it like it was turned out to be
a challenging task the subject of the
accident at Three Mile Island and the
response to it and the aftermath of it
is a complex and partly for that reason
I think it's so interesting such a good
subject to write history about a friend
of mine of a former government historian
sent me a letter a couple days ago and
he said to me well you probably couldn't
have written this book unless you had
written the other three books first
because that gave you the experience in
the background and and a knowledge to
deal with 3-mile and and and I think
that's exactly right I mean I could have
written a book but it would have been
not as good I think as I hope it is and
it certainly would have been a different
book and certainly the book that I wrote
on Three Mile Island draws heavily on
the experience and a knowledge that I've
gained as an NRC historian for almost 25
years in spite of that it was still not
an easy book to write and and I supposed
it that no book is easy to write but
this one was difficult in part because
of the technical issues and I'm not a
technical person I was trained as a
diplomatic historian so so the subject
of a nuclear regulation was not
something that came to me by training
it's come to me from experience and I
used to say sure I know how a reactor
working works it boils water and then
that creates steam and it drives a
turbine so I thought that's about all
that one had to know about nuclear power
the creation of nuclear power but for
this book on the TMI especially I
thought that I really had to to talk
about more than that it wasn't enough to
simply say that well you know what a
reactor does is to boil water so it was
difficult for me to try to explain
exactly what had happened and why on
of March 28 1979 and so and so that was
one side of what what made it for me a
challenging book to write the other side
was that I was trying to write a book
that I hoped would be readable a book
that would appeal to those who don't
have a broad knowledge of a nuclear
power or a nuclear power regulation and
and so I was trying to strike that
balance and when you we as historians we
all have to make choices about what we
include and what we don't include and
it's often a difficult choice but what I
was trying to do was write a book that
got the technology right but also
explained it in such a way that it would
make sense to someone who didn't have a
great deal of of a technical background
I'll tell you just a short story about
about something that happened to me
yesterday that made me feel good and
that was couple weeks ago I had a call
from a woman who works at the NRC as a
secretary in one of the offices at the
NRC and she asked me for a copy of the
book and so I signed it and I sent her
it over and I I happened to see her in
the hallway yesterday and she said to me
thank you for the book and I said well
great I'm glad you got it and she said
you wrote that book for me and I said I
did and she said yeah you wrote that
book for me because I read it and I
could understand it and she said you
just pick it up and you read it and and
I thought to myself cool you know that's
really great because what she said to me
her her comment to me meant more to me
than than my sending a book did to her
I'm sure so so I hope that was a sign
that that I'm reaching a broader
audience because people need to know
about Three Mile Island they need to
know about the nuclear regulation and
they need to know what happened and why
and that's that's the audience that I'm
trying to reach the book was also a
difficult to write I think because I
found it hard to to try to capture the
mood the anxieties the uncertainties the
acute tension the fear and the human
drama that was was so much a part of the
story in the response to Three Mile
Island and it's hard to do I think at
least at least it was hard for me to do
you know you can always string
Quotes together or string anecdotes
together and that's and that's one
approach but I don't think that's the
best one but to trying to choose the
right examples of the right anecdote or
the right to quotation is what I think
distinguishes good history or readable
history from from not-so-good history
and I hope that I've achieved my goal I
was pleased that one of the first book
reviews I've gotten has said the book
was riveting and I certainly hope that's
true I don't know if it is but I do know
that no one has ever said that about any
of my other books when when I first set
out to write this book I had a different
book in mind I was going to write a book
on the subject of a nuclear regulation
during the 1970s the first book that
George misison and I wrote covered in
1950s a second book that I that I wrote
after George left covered in 1960s and
the fourth book was a kind of a third
book excuse me it was a kind of a
sidebar on radiation protection and this
book then was going to be the third in
the chronological series that was going
to cover nuclear regulation during the
1970s and it was an enormous ly
important time for the subject of
nuclear power and nuclear power
regulation there were all kinds of
issues over reactor safety radiation
protection radioactive waste there was a
huge controversy over whether or not
plants were well enough protected from
attacks by terrorists this was not
something that has become a big issue
since 9/11 this was a big issue during
the 1970s it was also during this decade
that the a the NRC was established after
the the abolition of the Atomic Energy
Commission so it it was an enormously
important decade and a lot was going on
a great subject for a book and I thought
the culmination of that book then would
be a chapter or two one a Three Mile
Island accident I thought that that
would be a nice way to finish the book
to talk about all the issues that were
discussed and hotly debated during the
1970s and end with Three Mile Island
well once I got into my research on on
Three Mile Island
and read the documents and read the
transcripts and read the the thousands
of pages of documents and other material
about the accident I quickly decided
this book had to be about Three Mile
Island because the story is so
engrossing and so fascinating and so
important that I quickly concluded that
that it had to be the subject of its own
books so so what I did was to flip-flop
instead of a book on the 1970s with a
chapter two on
TMI I wound up with a book on TMI with a
couple of chapters about the 1970s and
that's okay I think that that was the
right decision
I suspect we wouldn't be having this
program today if I had written a book on
called a nuclear regulation during the
1970s so wouldn't be on c-span probably
not well I don't want to go on at the
great length I would simply add by way
of conclusion that the disc 1 2 right
and in the sense that it was
chronological it was a great story there
was lots of drama so it was challenging
and difficult but also enjoyable and the
book in some ways wrote itself
and I should say I suppose that I didn't
start with any preconceived ideas or
notions or any predetermined conclusions
I certainly didn't have any agenda I
mean I think I started off even though I
worked for the the NRC when I started
work on this book for probably for for
more than 20 years so I knew something
about three mile and and and I knew
something had happened you know there
was an evacuation there was a lot of
concern about a hydrogen bubble Harold
Denton the the the NRC's chief spokesman
at the site and and governor Thornburgh
and played important roles the president
had gone to visit there one day and I
kind of knew that stuff but I didn't
know a whole lot more so so what I did
was to look at all the sources and there
are
as I said thousands of pages of sources
transcripts and documents and
depositions and all kinds of wonderful
sources and what I hope I have done and
what I tried to do was to take all those
disparate and very rich sources which
were pieces of a puzzle and put the
puzzle together in a way that I hope
explains the accident explains what
happened and why and draw us some
conclusions about what happened and
where we have gone since the accident
occurred 25 years ago on Sunday great
well you called Three Mile Island the
worst accident in the history of
commercial nuclear power in the United
States so well tell us I did do that yes
what happened why was it why was it the
worst accident it was the worst accident
it was the worst accident because as
those of you who know who know a little
bit about about subject the court melted
I mean I mean the the worst kind of
accident you can have in a in a nuclear
power plan is to have the core melt and
and the core melted no one knew that at
the time we didn't find out until 1985
that the core had melted it was obvious
that that that something had gone
terribly wrong at the plan it was
obviously there had been damage to the
core but no one knew until 1985 that
you'd actually had a meltdown so truly
and in fact one one title the title that
I used for my book is the engrossing I
think Three Mile Island but one one one
title that I made jokes about with my
friends when they ask me what does they
ask what the title of this book will be
and I thought I said that I would I
thought I would call it melting the atom
which I and and that's what happened
there there was a meltdown so so so you
had a worst-case accident at Three Mile
Island well how'd it happen what went on
was it what caused it equipment failures
people something else yes yes yes you
you had some rather minor mechanical
breakdowns some equipment failed the
basic mechanical cause of the accident
was a valve that stuck open which
allowed coolant from the core to to rush
out of the pressure vessel and spill
over into the containment building of
the plant and within a few minutes or
than a fairly short time about 30,000
gallons of coolant had left the core
30,000 out of the 90,000 or so gallons
that were in the core and and even this
I mean this was not good you don't want
this to happen but it would have been
okay if the operators had recognized
what was going on but but they didn't
and and I don't want to hang the
accident on the operators at all because
they were in terrible position bells
were ringing lights were flash and a
hundred lights on the the monitors on
the in the control room were flashing
and they knew something was not right
but they didn't know what it was and and
there was no clear signal that this
valve was stuck open there were ways
that they might have concluded that if
all those lights hadn't been flashing if
they if they had had more opportunity to
step back and try to figure out that the
problem was that this valve was open but
they didn't do that and there was no
clear signal on the control panel that
said this valve is open if they had
known that and closed that valve the
accident at Three Mile Island would not
have been a meltdown and would
a rather minor mishap so it was
mechanical breakdowns and operator error
and one thing that we learned from the
accident is that no one had paid enough
attention to so-called human factors and
human factors played a very very large
role in the fact that you had a very
severe accident at Three Mile Island
what was the danger to the public was
there a chance the plant could blow up
the danger to the public was that if if
the containment building and I don't
have a diagram here and it's probably
good that there's not a chalkboard
because you wouldn't want want to have
me join a diagram but but the
containment building is the very large
concrete building that just surrounds
the reactor and it has walls at least at
Three Mile Island which which are four
feet thick reinforced concrete for four
feet thick and this building the
containment building is designed to
withstand the forces of any accident
problem was that no one could be
absolutely certain that it would do that
there was just no way to test in such a
way that you could be absolutely certain
that under some circumstances
containment would not fail so the danger
of the accident was that something could
happen that could cause a breach of the
walls of containment and allow massive
quantities of dangerous forms of
radiation to escape from the building
were they was there some concern if that
happened that you should evacuate people
what kind of debate was going on how are
people reaching conclusions about how
serious the problem was and how easy it
would be to to control that problem
that's about five questions Jeffrey no
come on
yes no baby and I'm not sure now the
question of whether or not to evacuate
the the the population to order and
evacuation was was the most
gut-wrenching decision that policy
makers had to make because and if you
come on Sunday you'll hear governor
Thornburgh and Harold Denton talk about
this governor Thornburgh who had to make
the final decision it was his call it
was not a call by the NRC and it was not
a call by the White House it was called
by the governor as to whether or not you
order an evacuation so the question
becomes do you take do do you tell the
population out to ten miles from the
plan out to 15 or perhaps even up to a
20-mile radius from the plan to evacuate
knowing that if you do that some people
are going to get killed some people are
going to be injured some people are
going to suffer severe economic losses
there's going to be a huge dislocation
of the population so do you order an
evacuation knowing that there are going
to be heavy costs no one knew how heavy
but still the cost of an evacuation are
going to be great in terms of lives in
terms of injuries and in terms of of
economic losses or do you assume that
the plant or do you based on your
judgment conclude that the plant is
going to hold that there's not going to
be a breach of containment and therefore
that there is not going to be a great
danger to the public so that was the
question that faced policymakers for the
five days of crisis that that followed a
Three Mile Island accident do you order
an evacuation knowing that there are
going to be costs or do you take a
chance that the plan is going to hold
and what made that so excruciating and
so difficult for policymakers was that
they didn't know exactly what the
condition of the plant was and and so
you're making judgments based on on on a
lack of total information you're making
judgments based on information that you
have that is probably accurate but night
but might not be and it's based on the
opinions
of knowledgeable people able people who
are trying their best to make certain
that the population is not threatened by
a breach of containment but who simply
can't be sure what the condition of the
plants are or what the chances are that
you might have a major release of
radiation and in that uncertainty and
when I talk about the mood of the times
uncertainty as always up close to talk
the top if you if you read the
transcripts from from from the tapes
that were kept in the NRC's Incident
Response Center which which is where the
the NRC's response was focused and and
and and the words that keep being used
over and over I wish we had more data I
wish we knew more this would be a lot
easier to know what to do if we knew
what the condition of the reactor was
and people didn't when the you had
incomplete data coming out was that
interpreted differently by different
groups yeah yeah Bob pundits is here and
Bob and Bob was deeply involved in what
turned out to be the major issue of the
whole crisis and that was the existence
of a hydrogen bubble that formed in the
top of the pressure vessel the pressure
vessel is a large container inside the
containment building which actually
holds the the the reactor core and as a
result of the accident you had a large
release or large formation the formation
of a large hydrogen bubble in the top of
the pressure vessel and the question
that arose and I won't get deeply into
this but the question that arose was can
that hydrogen bubble become flammable or
even explosive and if that happens then
you could lose the pressure vessel the
pressure vessel could fail it could it
could open up it could be fractured and
then you have the core in in the
containment building the last line of
defense and you don't want that so the
question is is there possibility for
either a flammable or an explosive
bubble that could
mean the loss of the Pressure Vessel an
extremely serious question caused caused
a major loss of sleep and a major
anxiety among people at the NRC both in
Bethesda and less so at the site and and
the big issue there was can there be the
development can there be the formation
of oxygen which can then become
flammable or perhaps over time explosive
and no one knew for certain and NRC
Bethesda said yeah we've got some free
oxygen which is forming there which
could which could be flammable could
over time be explosive and most of the
NRS are the NRC people at the site were
saying no you have so much hydrogen in
that bubble that if you have the
formation of oxygen is going to
immediately recombine with the hydrogen
to form water again so you don't have
any chance of a flammable or explosive
bubble and the question was is the rate
of recombination greater than the rate
of formation of free oxygen and that was
a very difficult question and it's not
surprising that experts came out with
different views and we should not be
surprised and it took them a couple days
to figure out in the end that no it
wasn't a problem those who said you
wouldn't have the formation of enough
free oxygen to be explosive or flammable
those people were right but for a couple
of days it was a close call and no one
knew for certain how did the general
public follow this issue but kind of
make me talk about the role of the media
how well they covered this and to what
extent yeah the public the public
depended for their primary source of
information for the people of central
Pennsylvania was radio because they
could get up-to-the-minute bulletins on
the radio and they also could get
streamers on their TV sets but but from
all that that I've read
their primary source was was radio in
terms of how the media handled the
accident in some ways they did well the
the media like the NRC and state of
Pennsylvania in the White House and and
everyone else who played a role in the
response to the accident the media was
in a terrible position because they
didn't know what was going on and and
and a lot of the reporters who were sent
to cover the accident didn't have the
foggiest notion what nuclear power was
all about I mean they covered other
beats but they needed somebody sent to
3-mile and so so so people got sent
there so it was less than an ideal
situation for anybody including
reporters especially those who hadn't
covered the topic previously how well
they did in some ways they did quite
well I think under the circumstances in
other ways they did very poorly and I'm
I'm generalizing here and and so I ask
your indulgence but on the hydrogen
bubble the press did extremely poorly
and and one cause that the the the
hydrogen bubble was was was a source of
the closest thing that the population
came to a panic occurred on on the
Saturday night of the accident the
fourth day of the accident those those
of us who write about the accident
always talk about Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday there's five days
and we always call them by the day so on
on Saturday night there there was a
great deal of concern because there
there had been a story written by The
Associated Press following a press
conference that was held by the chairman
of the NRC Joseph Henry which said and
and Henry had been asked and answered
quite honestly that yes the NRC was
concerned about the possibility of a
hydrogen explosion in the pressure
vessel and the story that ap wrote
mentioned that quite properly and also
said that an anonymous NRC source had
said that that the critical point
whatever that meant would could occur in
two days and the story was filled with
caveats but but what went out on the air
on the radio and on streamers that ran
across TV was NRC says explosion at
three mile and could happen in two days
so you can imagine how people responded
to that like any reasonable person would
scared the bejeebers out of people not
not only because of the possibility that
there might be an explosion and and you
can be sure I'm certain that most people
when they thought about an a hydrogen
explosion at Three Mile Island we're not
thinking about the possibility that you
might lose the pressure vessel and that
might cause the the core to fall into
the containment building and in a worse
case this might cause a breach of
containment no what they were thinking
about was if you have a hydrogen
explosion at Three Mile Island the roof
is going to blow off the building and
you're going to have an atomic bomb type
of situation so when this news was put
out and it was put out in the most
alarming possible fashion it caused a
near panic and I say near panic because
the population of the area surrounding
the plant behaved and I hesitate to use
that word but but acted in a way that
was extremely responsible there was no
panic there were no people who were
doing the things that people do when
they panic there's a great deal of
anxiety and a great deal of concern but
but the closest that the population
appears to have come to a situation
where they were just scared out of their
wit's was as a result of the of the
hydrogen bubble scare and and and the
scare was exaggerated far beyond reason
or proportion a a lot of people that
I've talked to when I asked them about
their memories between my alone and
people who lived not necessarily area
remember a couple things one Walter
Cronkite coming out and making an
announcement I thought maybe you say
something about that and the second
thing is more flip and it's away a lot
of people
to learn about politics now that is um
comedy shows like Saturday Night Live
you told how the the popular media
treated Three Mile Island the national
media the the the news programs on ABC
and CBS and NBC and and the national
newspapers tended to play up the hazards
the dangers the uncertainties more than
the local newspapers did to Harrisburg
papers the York papers the Lancaster
papers in general and not that they were
indifferent they were anything but but
but but but they tended to I want to
make this clear I I don't want to say
play down because they didn't do that
but they handled the dangers of the
accident in a better context the
national news programs tended to to
highlight the possibility that something
catastrophic might happen and I suppose
that's that's the nature of the business
and given what they knew it was not
unreasonable is a question of emphasis
and a question of headlines in terms of
Saturday Night Live and other comedy
programs when Saturday evening this was
this was following the the bubbles scare
in fact the governor and Harold Denton I
held a press conference late on Saturday
night eleven o'clock on on Saturday
night not to time when press conferences
are normally held and they they held the
press Congress to inform the press and
to inform of the people of central
Pennsylvania that yes the bubble could
be a problem but it was not an imminent
threat it was not going to blow up
overnight and it probably not not going
to blow up at all but but there was
something that had to be dealt with and
and and that helped to to at least
soothe the the worst fears of the
population and and and of those who were
involved in responding to the accident
that night and and this this press
conference was held late at night
Saturday Night Live that that evening
and this came on a short time after
Thornburg's press conference and they
and they announced that they were
holding a contest to name a new capital
of Pennsylvania to replace Harrisburg
and of course the press conference had
just been held in Harrisburg and so
Thornburg staff was outraged and
immediately immediately called NBC 2 to
protest and later on there were Saturday
night broadcasts that show president and
mrs. Carter with her yellow booties on
the president and mrs. Carter went to
through my own the next day on Sunday
and wore yellow booties when they toured
the plant and and in the grounds to
protect him from traces of radiation I
mean which was a smart thing to do but
cause of much levity later you mentioned
a an initial worried that the president
had been exposed to perhaps it an
unhealthy level of radiation what
happened in that episode what happened
was Harold Denton and and Harold Denton
who his his job at the NRC was headed
the office of nuclear reactor regulation
and and so he was in charge of licensing
the the licensing of and and the safety
of operating power plants and Harold
Denton turned out to be the hero of
3-mile and in in in many ways and and I
get that from
dick thornburgh who who I think says
that every chance he gets and Harold
Denton was was bureaucrat I mean he was
a guy who hadn't been highly visible he
was certain not a household name
Harold tells a story the first time that
he he went to the plant site on on
Friday at the request of President
Carter
I mean Carter had asked for the best
person in the country to go up there and
take over and so the NRC sent Denton and
so at that evening then Thornburg had
scheduled a press conference and he
asked Harold to come up for the press
conference and Denton got there and
Thornburgh had a statement that he
opened to press command and there were
200-300 reporters there I mean it was a
huge he was a mob scene and so the
governor made his opening statement and
Harold said well he was kind of sitting
there looking at the ceiling and
suddenly the governor said and now I'm
going to turn this over
- Harold Denton and he's going to he's
going to answer your questions and
Harold had never he'd had one press
briefing in his life so and after that
then he became the the focus of press
attention at Three Mile Island and and I
said that for a reason because I was
going to answer the question you
actually asked enough - one that I was
and a question was Jeffrey again I'm
sorry
the initial worry that after the
president came out of this oh yeah okay
okay right yeah I knew the question was
better than the answer when President
Carter went up on on Sunday then and he
landed that the at the airport at
Harrisburg in fact one of the person who
greeted him there was a congressman from
from Pennsylvania named Bob Walker who
was my brother and and who's also in the
audience so I should take this
opportunity to introduce him but Harold
Denton led Thornburg and and and Carter
and mrs. Carter on on a tour of the plan
and and they all were those senators to
make certain that they didn't get a over
exposure to to radiation while they were
touring to playing with their booties
own I mean that's that's that's why they
wore their booties so after the after
the tour was over and and there's a
famous picture of the four of them in
the control room with their booties on
so after that was over then the
technicians for the utility met Edie
check their dosimeter just to make
certain they hadn't gotten an exposure
and Herald Denton's dosimeter which the
NRC had issued read zero dick Thornburgh
dosimeter which had been issued by the
state of Pennsylvania read zero the DOE
seminars for President and mrs. Carter
read about a hundred milligrams now
that's not a terribly dangerous dose but
still if for for Harold who said it if
he was going to have a heart attack
during the three mile and crisis it's
that this is a time that would have had
it because hear his dosimeter was zero
the governor's was
and the president and mrs. Carter had
we're showing a dose of a hundred
milligrams well it turned out that that
in fact the the dosimeter is that the
president and the first lady war had
been issued by the utility which didn't
clear them after each usage what they
did was to subtract the current reading
from the previous reading and so once
they did that that subtraction turned
out that in fact the exposure of the
president and first lady was the same as
for Harold Denton and governor
Thornburgh zero but it took a few
minutes for them to figure that out and
and Harold said those were bad bad times
I mean this is a guy you know who'd been
living through five days of crisis and
he said if I was gonna have a heart
attack that was a time since mention you
had two chapters leading up in the book
that talks about the 1970s in the
context for regulation and you deal with
public attitudes can you comment on two
things what was the health of the
nuclear power industry and then I want
you to talk about attitude public
attitudes about nuclear power prior to
the accident industry had his boom years
between the late 1960s and the mid 1970s
and almost all the plants if not all
them which are now in operation 103
plants were under construction at that
time and and a lot of them opened in
that time period what happened in the
mid and later 1970s what this was that
the nuclear industry underwent a slump
and it was a slump which was largely a
result one from high inflation of the
1970s as you probably know what nuclear
power power plants are capital intensive
so when you have inflation it's it's
it's very expensive to borrow money at
the same time you also had a recession
going on and so you had a diminished
demand for power and so plants that were
started with the idea that that the
increase in demand for power was going
to keep keep growing at a rate of about
to seven percent a year that turn
doubt not to be true so by the mid in
late 1970s the nuclear industry was
complaining bitterly that the wave of
the future seemed to have washed out
because orders for four new plants fell
off drastically so even before Three
Mile Island the industry was was in a
slump and we're very concerned about
about about at least a rate of growth in
the future in terms of public attitude
the the the other major development of
the 1970s in terms of the public and a
nuclear power was that you had two
growth of nuclear power as a major
headline making national issue
increasingly throughout the 1970s so
that so that it was enormous ly
controversial by the time of Three Mile
Island and and it's hard to read the
polls and one never knows exactly how to
quantify these things but but clearly
they're even even before three-mile and
there was diminishing public support for
and especially growing ambivalence
toward the use of nuclear power as a
major source of electricity for the
United States what happened after Three
Mile Island was that much of that
ambivalence turned to opposition and
certainly Three Mile Island greatly
enhanced the credibility of nuclear
critics it deepened the slump of the
nuclear power industry and I think even
today that if you ask people something
about nuclear power which most of us
don't do but but if you did the first
thing that somebody would think would be
Three Mile Island and what they remember
about Three Mile Island is is the
uncertainty is - fear and is the anxiety
of all that that went on
during those five days of crisis how did
that crisis in for the public what made
people relax and feel confident that
things were under control when when it
became clear by Sunday afternoon that
the
and bubble was was was not an issue that
the hydrogen bubble was not going to
cause an explosion or even flammability
that that was the most that that was the
key issue by that time and that was was
the source of most of the anxiety at
least on a part of the public when it
was clear that that that issue had been
resolved there were still issues to be
dealt with in the NRC and the White
House from state of Pennsylvania were
still concerned about other other things
that were happening at the plant but the
resolution of the bubble issue was was
really the end of the immediate crisis
at least I hope so because that's what I
say in my book you mentioned the worst
possible thing could happen as a
meltdown but yet people didn't know what
had happened during that crisis what
went on how long did it take to find out
what happened and how was that
discovered by I mean the problem was of
course that you couldn't send somebody
into the plant to find out you couldn't
open up the pressure vessel to see what
the condition of the core was and so as
the cleanup of the plant was starting to
get underway they had to find out what
had happened as a result of the accident
and they did probes down where they put
tiny cameras down down through the
control rods and in 1982 they found out
when when they did the first probe that
where the control rods used to be there
was nothing I mean a formal term is a
void and that's what it was I mean I
mean a camera was looking around and it
was a void so so they knew that that
that something very serious had happened
more serious than at least some people
anticipated some people were we're not
surprised and some people were no one
knew again for certain finally in 1985
when
when when when the experts and the
technicians who were involved in in
preparing the the plant for cleanup got
the lid of the pressure vessel open and
had a chance to see what it actually
happened they realized that there had
not only been severe damage to the core
about about half of it had turned liquid
it had melted it had been in a liquid
state and that's not good and that's
what what people had always worried
about is the worst thing that can happen
a meltdown of the core so that was not
good news it was much more severe than
anyone had realized at the time of the
accident it was much more severe than
anyone realized when governor Thornburgh
and others were trying to make decisions
about whether or not to evacuate the
population I mean I'm certain and I'm
sure that that Thornburg and Denton and
others had told me that if anyone had
known in 1979 that the Corps had in fact
melted that the NRC would have
recommended the White House would have
recommended and governor Thornburgh
would surely have ordered a general
evacuation of the population of the area
perhaps out as far as 20 miles and keep
in mind 20-mile radius included six
hundred and thirty six thousand people
13 hospitals and a prison so an
evacuation of that magnitude would have
been a major major undertaking what were
the long-term effects of the the
accident on public health the state of
the the industry whatever factors you
consider but mainly a health I think
people were concerned there were some
releases of radioactivity what was a
release from the plan went out to stack
it's not as though the containment
building was breached but but
radioactive gases were released out the
stack off and on throughout the five
days of crisis and and and and even
after that and those those releases were
almost entirely noble gases and the
noble gases are much
dangerous and other forms of radiation
because they don't combine with body
tissue the most dangerous forms of
radiation that you worry about the most
are our isotopes like iodine 131 cm 137
strontium 90 volatile radioactive
elements that can and do combine with
body tissue and that can cause cancer so
that's what you worry about the
measurements that were done of radiation
after the accident a indicated that yes
there were some releases but very small
releases of iodine 131 and not releases
of the other dangerous forms of
radiation the most dangerous forms of
radiation just to give you a comparison
I don't want to go into great too temp
great depth today about Chernobyl but at
Chernobyl there were literally millions
of Curie's which is a measurement of
radioactivity millions of Curie's of
iodine 1 131 released at Three Mile and
there were 20 carries and and since that
time there have been a number of health
studies of the effects of the accident
on public health and by and by they they
have been reassuring they are still
going on we still don't know exactly
what the health effects might be long
term but the the gold standard of the
health health studies that have been
done came out a year and a half ago done
by a team of experts at the University
of Pittsburgh where where they have a
cohort of people 32,000 people who lived
within a five-mile radius of the plant
and and for those people for the people
in that cohort they have health
histories previous exposure exposure to
radiation you know x-ray exposure where
they were and that type of thing and at
least for that cohort there has been no
evidence of increased incidence of
cancer so so at least so far
the the the the bottom line appears to
be that that the accident did not have a
major effect on on public health
whenever there is a major accident or
tragedy in the country typical response
is to have a commission study what went
wrong is there anything that we can
learn any reforms it should be imposed
what happened to the studies of Three
Mile Island and what recommendations
were made yeah a short time after the
accident a very short time after the
accident to President Carter formed a
commission to study the effects or study
the accident at Three Mile and chaired
by the president of the Dartmouth
College John G Kemeny and the Kemeny
Commission undertook a major
investigation of the causes and effects
of the accident and reported to
President Carter that the following that
that that November the Commission was
appointed in April and and and submitted
their final report in November the the
NRC also sponsored its own investigation
which was headed by a prominent attorney
named Mitchell Rogovin which also did a
very extensive investigation of the
causes and the consequences of the
accident and reported to the NRC and
both of these these these reports were
published in in summary forum and both
of them have thousands of pages of
supporting documentation and material
and what they concluded was that there
had been a lot of foul-ups by the NRC by
the nuclear industry and by others and
proved conclusively that no one was well
prepared for an accident such as
occurred at Three Mile Island and they
made a series of recommendations most of
which were
we're carried out and that was to
improve training of operators to improve
instrumentation in control rooms so if
you had alarms going off like you had on
the morning to March 28th the Three Mile
Island that that there would be be
something to show the operators what was
happening there were studies done of
better ways to control accidents there
were studies done on hydrogen control to
avoid problems like you had with the
hydrogen bubble there were studies done
of human factors in general control room
design all kinds of things were done as
a result of the accident to try to make
certain that you didn't have another
Three Mile Island well I'd like to turn
now to to you in the audience to present
Sam with any questions you have to do so
a task that you'd walk up to one of the
two microphones in the aisle to ask your
question yes low I have two questions I
think I have met people in the area were
restaurant owners or farmers who believe
they had some radiation exposure
themselves they feel their land was
contaminated or the rivers and I believe
they had suits against whoever the
government my question is was any of
that valid and what's happened to the
results of the suits my second question
is I believe Janet Sherman toc-toc stock
has been doing studies of teeth residue
and teeth could you comment on her
studies the first question on whether or
not there was radiation in in the area
surrounding plant yeah there was some
noble gases but you know radiation can't
hide and there weren't enough dosimeter
czar there weren't enough instruments
spread around the plant to know exactly
how much radiation there was at any
given point at any given
but fact remains that radiation is not
easy to hide if there had been major
releases of any magnitude they would
have shown up in milk or in bread or or
in foodstuffs or in agricultural
products there were stories of severe
illnesses on the part of animals farm
animals in the area surrounding Three
Mile Island and those were I think taken
very seriously but but what the studies
which were done by the State Department
of Agriculture showed was that the
animal illnesses came not from radiation
and working and weren't the kind of
illnesses that could have occurred from
radiation but from infections so so
according to the evidence we have and
the evidence is not going to be complete
but according to the best evidence we
have and and and it's as good as we can
get the evidence indicates that there
were no major releases of volatile forms
of radiation and and it's very easy to
understand why people would would feel
uncertain about that and very easy to
feel like like someone was not being
upfront with them but I certainly have
never seen any evidence of anyone trying
to cover up or anyone trying trying to
play down what the effects were or the
possible effects of the accident and I'm
sorry your second question dealt with
with study yeah and and I don't know
about her studies specifically I do know
something about other studies that have
been done of teeth we show strontium 90
and and and that's not good the the the
the results that that I know about and
and that's all I can speak to is is that
the strontium 90 which has been found in
populations sometimes close to a nuclear
power plants that the strontium 90 has
is
apparently come from Bom Bom testing
during the 1950's yeah yeah but but but
they have in very small amounts ELISA
studies that I have seen and it
certainly are not conclusive in terms of
their being major exposures by the
population
my favorite Saturday Night Live skit
with us was Ed Asner going off on a
fishing trip saying now if something
happens you can't add too much water and
of course the lights go off and the crew
is saying now did he say you you can't
add too much because any amount the add
is really good or is he saying it just
can't add too much and it is sitting
there in the fishing boat and there's
this huge hydrogen bomb and he's saying
yep they added too much water the
question is what's the status of the
plant I presume it's is it still there
and nobody goes in it or is it a
National Historic Site in there doing
tours what's the what's the long-term of
Three Mile Island yes the plan is still
there it has been cleaned up the water
there were hundreds of thousands of
gallons of the contaminated water the
plant was was was cleaned up the so so
the the innards of the plan had been
scrubbed down and cleaned up and and and
the reactor itself is now in storage out
in in Idaho or Hanford Hanford or Idaho
not in Pennsylvania which is good
because I Drive past Airlines I was a
joke and the other part of your question
was oh oh is it a National Historic Site
no I mean I mean the cooling towers are
still there the containment building is
still there the the twin plan or the
near twin plan it's not exactly a twin
but it's close is operating but but Unit
two where the accident was is is a
mausoleum I I had a tour of it when I
started to do work on my book I went up
there and had a nice tour
my own dosimeter unfortunately when I
got done I didn't have any exposure
which I which I felt good about but I
didn't get inside the containment
building so so yes it's there but but
but at least the most dangerous results
of the accident have been cleaned up you
mentioned yet you hope your book met the
standards of historical scholarship
what are those standards just very
briefly and who sets them you know
that's very good question let me tell
you what I think they are and and we
have a few historians in the only in
fact my my advisor my dissertation
adviser Wayne Cole is here today so
maybe I should ask Wayne about that if I
if I if I say something wrong Wayne
might be up here on the platform with me
so to to to me the key standard of
historical scholarship is that you is is
that you is is that you don't base your
writing on predetermined conclusions
that you don't start off with your
conclusions and then try to fit the
evidence into what you have already
decided and and I suppose that's obvious
but there's an awful lot of bad history
that's written because somebody has
something that they're trying to prove
and then they go and find evidence that
they think will will support that point
of view to me that's doing history
backwards what you have to do to start
with an open mind I mean we all have
knowledge we all have biases and and
those need to be acknowledged and
recognized but but we need to gather
collect as much evidence as we can and
draw our conclusions based on on the
evidence that we collect and and that
often leads to a lot of surprises and
that's as it should be so so in terms of
my own views and and others might have
different priorities but but to me that
is the gold standard of historical
scholarship
related to the previous one
as a federal historian or as a
government historian you are subject to
the rules and regulations of the federal
government and some people could
criticize you for being a house
historian or a captured historian and
could you comment on that by the way
this is George from Susan who used to be
my colleague at the NRC George George
hired me yeah you know I think it's true
for most historians if not all
historians in the federal government
that that one assumes that that there's
a party line of some kind that you're
expected to to follow and yeah
addressing I mean my answer is the same
as this gentleman's I think no one at
the NRC has has ever told me or told you
and me that there's something we need to
conclude has has never said oh you can't
talk about that because that might be
embarrassing no one has ever said watch
out for that subject because that's kind
of sensitive no one has ever said
wouldn't it be nice if you if you made
us look good
you know don't you think you're being a
little harsh or no one has ever expected
me to do anything other than call it as
I see it and and that's why I said when
I started I think I've got the best job
in the federal government from for my
purposes and and my interest in my
training because you know I get paid to
write history as I see it and and I
don't think you can do any better than
that
so so a George asks a question that we
all encounter because some people are
inclined to think that that well you
know if your federal historian that that
that that what you write is tainted and
and I hope that's not true
of any of us and I know it's not true in
the case of what I write and what George
and I wrote you know I'm not saying it's
always right but I am saying I insist
that it's always honest and and that's
the best I can do and we'll say Sam's
writings have appeared in the best
journals in the country that I have to
pass through a rigorous peer review as
anybody submissions would and that your
books have been published by the
University of California Press which
goes through a peer-review process I'm
Bob bud knits and Sam mentioned me about
a half an hour ago I was a senior
officer at the NRC at the time was the
deputy director of research and I was in
that Incident Response Center those
whole five days my colleague Steve Hanna
are sitting just one meter away was
there for the think of that to those
long 16-hour days I thought you did an
excellent job of capturing what went on
and anybody that thinks it's a whitewash
ought to read the book because it is
absolutely as critical of the NRC as is
appropriate because the NRC and we were
there didn't do as good a job as we
might have to as well as others so the
utility didn't do a good job either that
aside there's been a lot of change since
three months 25 years and you've been at
the agency the whole time do you want to
comment about how how the NRC in the
industry have evolved since that time
and also come in if you can about why
the public should trust the NRC to be
the regulator of nuclear power safety
the way we trust the FAA to regulate
aircraft safety sure I'm glad to answer
that let me let me think about that for
a second how the NRC and the industry
have changed through now Alan was
certainly a turning point for a nuclear
power and for nuclear power regulations
everything changed after 3-mile and
through my land changed everything in
the sense that it's it's not as though
people were indifferent to safety prior
to three-mile and in fact the opposite
was true and as not as though people
were not concerned about the possibility
of an accident because they were but
their focus was on equipment there there
that their focus was on the hardware of
the plant and and they were on
evident if not complacent that if the
hardware function okay that you you
could have accidents you could have
missed naps but you were very very
unlikely to the point of in credibility
of having an accident that that was
going to breach containment three-mile
and changed all that and it changed all
that because the equipment worked worked
fine except for that valve is stuck open
the equipment was fine and and and when
the loss-of-coolant accident began after
the valve stuck opened the emergency
core cooling systems which are designed
to pour water onto the core if coolant
is being lost to replace that coolant
came on just as they were supposed to
problem was the operators turned them
off and what had not been anticipated
was that you might have an accident in
which operators take actions which
defeat the the design of the plan which
which override the safety equipment that
was so carefully constructed and
carefully placed in the plan so so in
terms of how the possibility the
probability and the risks of accidents
was concerned a great deal more emphasis
on on operator training on control room
design on on human factors to to try to
avoid another three-mile and I had an
interview with a reporter this morning
and he said he said what do we do to
make certain that we don't have a Homer
Simpson in in one of those plants and
and I said well you know I was kind of
taken back and I it was a good question
I suppose and I said well you know the
training is much more more more rigorous
than it was then and and we hope that
that the requirements were people who
own and operate the plants are one more
rigorous than they were then and to that
we don't get complacent like we got then
that that the major problems had been
resolved and and we didn't have to worry
too much about and have a major breach
of containment in terms of the industry
the
the industry as it should have took the
accident very seriously made a lot of
changes in how the industry regulated
itself there's an organization called
the Institute for nuclear power
operations which was formed as a result
of the accident that that was intended
to and in fact does serve as the Asian
for self policing of the industry by the
industry that works in collaboration
with the NRC to make certain that
regulations are followed that things are
done to make certain that that you don't
have another severe accident like Three
Mile Island and and all the time and III
think we're probably more humble than
than we were in 1979 because I think and
I hope that people at the NRC and I
think they do from all my contacts they
do also realize that that you can't get
complacent you have to realize that
there's always a risk involved in the
generation of nuclear power and that we
have to reduce those risks as much as
possible and and hopefully we build
plants in such a way that even if you
have a worst-case accident like you had
at Three Mile Island that once again
containment has not breached and ba-bye
forgotten a second part of your question
okay thank you
I confess to being an average American
and of my knowledge of a nuclear power
and the 70s was that we're gonna have
this bubble that was gonna blow up and
do an atom bomb so I thank you for
taking that a little advanced beyond
that level but I am curious about
Chernobyl and what might have been
learned from there if you could explain
a little bit about the dynamics of what
happened in Chernobyl that made that
such a bad accident as opposed to ours
which was a not necessarily as bad
accident and it was there anything from
that that we've then been able to bring
back and use in our own nuclear power
yeah yeah let me talk about that very
briefly and and that's a good question
and and and and the answer is Chernobyl
Chernobyl was worse than Thames Island
by orders of magnitude I mean there was
a major release a huge release of the
worst kinds of radiation and Chernobyl
was a disaster Three Mile Island was not
a disaster at least from what we know
now and Chernobyl was and and and there
were a couple of differences one has to
do with the design of the plant and I'm
not going to talk about negative
temperature coefficients because I
couldn't if I wanted to but suffice to
say that the temperature coefficients at
the Chernobyl LED were are a runaway
reaction and that happened because the
operators took out their control rods
and turned off the safety systems with
which I hope is one lesson we all learn
that it's not a good idea to do that in
a nuclear power plant and and it was
also worse because because the Russians
at least for the for the design of
plants that Chernobyl was didn't didn't
think that containment buildings were
necessary and and we still can't be
certain that a containment building is
going to contain a worst-case accident
we think that that it will and they're
certainly designed to do that but but in
the case of trinova there was no
containment building so so there was no
engineered structure to to hold in the
radioactivity that was was released in
huge quantities
at Chernobyl okay well thank you Sam
very much thank you thank you all for
being good